do men and women have the same levels of
upper body strength do you
think I think it is possible for a woman
to be as strong as either one of you not
even close not even close that uh I
don't know what that goofballs name is
but that guy that was like the male
swimmer he was a competitive swimmer he
ranked like 462 in the world sucked and
then he decided that he wanted to
identify as a woman that he competed
against women and came in first place
and took all their medals it's not even
close like men and women have completely
different levels of upper body strength
men men and women are very very
different and I think that one of the
big mistakes that women make is they try
to like paint this this canvas of
everything's the same men get get
tattoos so I can get tattoos you know
men can be promiscuous without impunity
so so can I right it's like men and
women are different in so many ways and
that's good it's actually good like I
don't want a carbon copy of myself I'm
not gay I don't want to deal with a dude
that's exactly like me I want feminine I
want Beauty I want softness I want
culinary skills I want things that
complement my life that are different
right and I think that one of the great
mistakes a lot of women make today and
I've noticed this over and over again
now that we've done a whole bunch of
these U sequences now MF is that women
tend to say like we're Partners or we're
equal or we're the same do you guys see
the problem in that or is that not
something that you see because like
clearly what is happening here for you
gals is it's not working out for you
like you've got two different kids from
two different fathers you're in a
scenario where you're single in your 30s
you know we've got Jillian who wants to
be a stay-at-home mom but she's spent
you know her you know her youth
essentially chasing Excellence climbing
the corporate ladder you know doing all
these things to sort of become that
version of herself like do you see how
this isn't really working out or is it
working out I mean didn't I acknowledge
that though yeah yeah we've had some
conversations about that but I think
that Jordan's you know struggling with
some of these Concepts though well first
first of all I'm content being single
I'm I'm having fun I'm not putting any
pressure on that if something comes
along in its right fit it's right fit um
they'll probably like tattoos so I don't
think I'm going to have to worry or
really think um there's an endless
supply of men out there that will look
past tattoos look past your kids from
two different fathers there's loads of
guys out there loads yeah and I'm not
worried about it I'm not but are they
the kind of guys that you want to get
with that you'll invite into your
life um I mean maybe I don't know how
would I know how long have you been
single now um about two a year and a
half okay so a year and a half and the
last guy you said that you got divorced
from you end up paying him child support
in
alimony so would you say it's fair to
say that some of the choices you've made
in the past aren't really working out
for you yeah I mean I think in the past
year and a half I've also realized like
where like my faults and where um you
know my level of discernment is not
there or where like it to be um so I'm
just I've taken that and stride and I'm
just moving forward and you know
whatever happens happens type of
mentality um but yeah I'm not like I'm
not really looking I'm not out there
like searching I I would prefer to like
meet someone in the wild um and it's
just do really what sort of um what sort
of self-reflection what sort of
ownership um you know have you taken for
your past um so I'm I'm quick to put on
the rose colored glasses and and dismiss
the things that I would see as a red
flag um so I'm trying to be more care
yourself or with other people no like
within other people okay yeah um so I'm
I'm trying to um just look at things a
little more cautiously and within
yourself like what areas have you taken
ownership for um so like a big issue of
my past relationship was um my
communication I was a big
stonewaller um and I just I stopped
doing that um started opening up and
having like an open line of
communication um in just every
relationship friendships you know
platonic relationships whatever so um I
think I got a lot better have you
changed any your views or opinions on on
like any of the three red flags that
we've talked about the single mom the
friendships and the tattoos no so you
think that men and women can be friends
Yes sounds like you're still
stonewalling no that is not Stone in
stonewalling is I am having a discussion
with you about it stonewalling is saying
I will not have this discussion with you
refusing to engage you're you're locking
out other ideas right and I'm not say
not I completely welcomed this
conversation just because I disagree
with you that is not stonewalling okay
well tomato tomato I guess then no it's
like the definition is
it yes stonewalling means I will not
engage with you okay but Jordan I mean
like let's be honest here right like the
results I've gotten out of my life are
far better than the results you've
gotten out of your life I charge people
$5,000 an hour for my time privately
when I have consults with them I deal
with athletes actors politicians
entrepreneurs I'm trying to be useful
you know to you here and offer some
value but you're sitting there going
nope nope nope NOP nope nope NOP if it
comes if it comes you know sort of thing
like do you ever think that delivery has
something to do with people absorbing
your message my delivery I also ask
I don't know you seem you seem to really
lack any sort of compassion or humility
it seems to be a lot of wanting to catch
people in their mistakes or what they've
done wrong to prove your point and it
seems really weird honestly like I have
a hard time believing that someone wants
to pay you $5,000 for that and I good
for you that's amazing but at the same
time it doesn't shock me that femes
wouldn't want to be guys I've dealt with
now right like I have this for a reason
yeah I mean that's great but like I mean
I feel like what you're trying to do is
kind of like the Jordan Peterson thing
but to be honest with you he has Jordan
Peterson I don't even like Jordan
Peterson's stuff how is this I tell that
you wouldn't I can tell that you
wouldn't he's got an absurd series on
his daily wire a three-part Series where
he marches men into the slaughterhouse
of marriage offers no useful advice
whatsoever just man up lift up your
skirt be a man take your vows and get
married that's his advice have you have
you engaged with like his book 12 rules
for life or anything like that yeah it's
very average it's very basic stand up
straight clean your room wash your dick
it's basic stuff and you think what
you're offering is different it's
absolutely different it's actually
useful okay yeah I don't know about that
rich I feel like you lack the depth and
the wisdom that he has you're a
35-year-old that's single that that ran
through her 20s and early 30s climbing
the corporate ladder you've made some
mistakes here yeah I didn't say that I
didn't yeah you haven't made mistakes in
your life Rich we've all made mistakes
exactly yeah so what's the problem what
what was your point in saying that you
trying to invalidate my point of view by
saying that that I made mistakes in my
past I'm I'm I'm trying to hold you to
the fire here like I'm trying to make
make it clear to you that there's
certain things in life that require
ownership and I think that a lot of the
no you don't think that you should take
ownership for certain things in life I
think I did take
ownership I think you sound very
condescending when you say that well
yeah I mean I keep hearing you say that
you want me to deliver the message
differently so how should I deliver the
message I think that you should do a
better job at empathizing with people
and their POS positions and what they've
gone through I mean obviously Someone
Like Jordan you know you keep pointing
out that she's a single mom and she has
two kids with two different dads and you
keep kind of holding that up as this way
to almost discredit her and discredit
her position which I don't think she's
saying that she hasn't made mistakes and
done something wrong but to be quite
honest you really you sound like an
[__] and the truth is you might have
like really good points but but they're
not Landing because of the way you're
positioning yourself it's weird so again
I mean I'm asking you for a better
solution so whenever somebody criticizes
me and says I don't like the way that
you say something or you've done
something or the advice that you've
dispensed what is your better solution
my better solution is to maybe engage
with people a little more and try to
understand no I'm asking you what your
solution is to many of these problems
that I've tackled like you know for
example if you know if we're talking
about vetting you know where we're going
to vet somebody for a long-term
relationship and I dispense advice like
hey guys you know you probably shouldn't
deal with a woman that's got you know
male friends right like you're exposing
your relationship to unnecessary risk
right like I'm looking for some guidance
from you Jillian because you're offering
it and I'm not trying to be
condescending I'm not trying to do it
any other way than just what is your
better solution to a lot of the problems
that I've tackled here so I wasn't
talking about that point in particular I
was talking about generally speaking the
way you've conducted yourself in this
conversation
like it seems like you keep holding up
people's past mistakes as a way of disc
supposed to learn from your past
mistakes like isn't that why we're
talking about them yeah I don't think
any of us are arguing that okay but for
some reason you keep asserting yourself
as more intelligent than me because of
the fact that I'm 35 and single and
you're old with a girlfriend and I'm
still I'm still trying to get some
clarity here from you Jillian on how you
would solve the the problems that I've
tackled aside from being
nicer that's not the advice I was giving
you think I think the problem here I'm
trying to get to is what advice to
tackle the problems that I've dealt with
are you dispensing because you're
criticizing so I'm saying you know be a
be a a Critic you don't like what I'm
talking about or you don't like how I
deliver what I talk about so what is
your I don't like no no no I don't no
you're misunderstanding me I don't like
the way you're addressing the people in
this conversation so you agree with what
I'm saying you just don't like how I
deliver what I'm saying um I've
disagreed with some of what you're
saying but I've agreed with some of what
you've said
too you see how we go go in some circles
with this right like I'm completely open
to the criticism I welcome the criticism
I want critics to come on these shows
and have these conversations because I
think they're great conversations but I
want you to bring a solution to the
problem yeah so my solution would be
when someone opens up to you and they
say hey like you know I'm 35 I climbed
the corporate ladder I wish I would have
done things different and I'm trying to
navigate the dating world and we're
having a conversation and you keep
saying well Jillian you're 35 and spent
your 20s climbing the corporate ladder
like it's do you understand what I'm
saying like the way that you're holding
those things up and the way that you're
addressing us with those things it comes
across as condescending where it's like
you might have a great message and a
great solution but that's going to fall
on deaf ears when you preface it that
way you are not more intelligent than us
you are not more valuable than us just
because you know you have a different
perspective or you have different
results we're just trying to have a
conversation and it seems like you're
trying to assert yourself as we're
talking about feelings here so Jillian
like I get it let's just take the
feelings we'll set those aside for a
minute what I'm what I'm trying to get
from you
here what I'm trying to get to here is
you've criticized some of the things
that we've talked about Jordan is openly
criticized I mean she said that she
disagrees with most of what I say I am
inviting you to provide a solution to a
lot of the common problems that exist in
I mean the stuff that we've talked about
is mostly dating and relationships I'm
inviting you to bring some solutions to
me that are better aside from I don't
like your tone right that's really not
what I said you're putting words in my
mouth and I feel like that's another way
crediting what I'm saying no that's not
what I said your tone is fine it's the
way you're delivery the tone the way
it's being what you're saying what but
what are your better Solutions okay so
let's set that aside emotions aside fine
what is the better solution to all of
these problems anyone pick anyone you
know that I've addressed and just let me
know what your better solution is to
that problem I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out